and I sit down with my mom she's like  damn I got some advice for you on aging  and I'm thinking she's going to give me  these like wise words or something and  she's like my mom told me this and I  need you to know that when you sit you  need to stand up quick it'll take 20  years off your age everyone will think  you're a young person when you get up  you gotta stand up fast Dan okay that I  have to admit something to you that  happened the other night to me on a date  um I'm on a date I twisted my ankle like  oh God nine months ago now and but it  still really hurts and I tore ligaments  and like my foot is just straight up  screwed up and I was on a date and I  stood up to go to the bathroom and it  like kicked in the pain and so I like  waddled away from the table and I was  like well that's not sexy so I mean I  would have loved for your mom to see  that moment not only did I not stand up  fast I didn't walk away I waddled away